à Saint-Benoît-sur-Loire la terrasse du
belvédère offre une vue imprenable sur
l'église abbatiale et son jardin qui ces
derniers jours a enfin revêtu son habit
printanier après un bon bain de soleil
rien de mieux que de se cultiver un peu
sur cette édifice roman du 11e siècle
la première idée a été de fondée un
musée pour conserver les pièces du dépôt
lépidaire de l'abbaye et finalement
c'est le concept de centre
d'interprétation qui s'est imposée un
centre d'interprétation c'est pas tout à
fait comme un musée c'est un lieu qui
raconte l'histoire de l'abbaye mais à
l'aide d'autres outils un peu plus
innovants et dans l'ère du temps
finalement puisqu'on a ici des
multimédias des vidéos et des maquettes
aussi qui racontent cette histoire de
manière ludique
et sur votre parcours à travers
l'histoire vous pourrez même peut-être
faire connaissance avec l'un des anciens
habits
j'ai été confiée par les parents à
l'abbaye de Fleury
afin d'embrasser le service de Dieu
[Musique]
et de parfaire mon éducation
mais le belvédère ce n'est pas que de
l'histoire c'est aussi rencontré la
culture au sens large en témoigne cette
exposition temporaire 19 tableaux de
curiosité prêté par le Muséum d'Histoire
Naturelle d'Orléans
le but pour nous c'est vraiment de faire
sortir les musées Orléanais pour être
visible du public local ici du
territoire donc on sert vraiment de
relais entre les grands lieux de culture
et le public autre curiosité ce
rhinocéros grandeur nature qui a pris
ses quartiers ici jusqu'au 25 juin nous
on fait le lien avec les bestiaires
médiévaux donc qui représentait des
animaux en lien avec les moralités de
l'époque et le rhinocéros lui en fait il
avait pas sa place dans ses bestiaires
puisque les hommes d'Occident ne le
connaissaient pas et ça serait en fait à
partir de là que serait né la légende de
la Licorne le rhinocéros est devenu
petit à petit la licorne médiévale
le belvédère a accueilli 8000 curieux en
2022 et espère un jour atteindre la
barre des 15000 visiteurs par an